hey what's going on everybody what is
going on you know so many times in life
you asked that question but do you
really mean it
what's going on how are ya
i am um this is bill burr and this is
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast recorded
on a wednesday
just to see how you guys are doing how's
it going how's it going in your life are
you trudging are you are you taking care
of yourselves
what are you doing right now you're
sitting on a plane
huh you're driving to work
you're dragging your ass to the gym
oh god i don't want to [ __ ] do this
anymore there's only one time a man
likes going to the gym and that's when
he's working out his upper body
that is the only time if you can get the
packs and the [ __ ] decks and the
chest and all the for your testicles and
your [ __ ] biceps going i love those
gym days
cardio days leg days
ugh
the only part of leg day i like is is
that you get to sit down on all the
machines
i'm too old to be doing standing squats
and all of that [ __ ]
what am i what i got a [ __ ] nfl
combine coming up i love seeing these
people putting like crazy amounts of
weight
crazy amounts of weight doing [ __ ]
squats and every time they go down i'm
like his [ __ ] knees are just gonna
they're gonna that's it's
it's not gonna be good when you get to
be my age people
it's like you're doing neutral drops
with your [ __ ]
body does that even exist anymore does
anybody remember a neutral drop is it
all just an electric car now
i saw a guy go buy me yesterday on a
[ __ ] electric motorcycle it was
impressive
although i kind of feel like all the
skill of riding a motorcycle was being
able to shift and downshift and making
the engine work for you
so i just wonder with those things
how if you're going too fast into a turn
and you don't want to you don't want to
touch your brakes because you feel like
you're going to go down you could
usually downshift and let the engine
slow down the bike
how does that work how does downshifting
work
when we return electric bicycles
electric motorcycles sorry
it's good for the environment but bad
for humans
um
anyway um
did i mention i saw that movie don't
look up
i really enjoyed that movie
um slash felt they were making fun of me
slash felt i was one of the aware p
aware
people
i kind of felt like i was everybody in
that movie um
magnificent performances um you should
check it out i believe it's on netflix
um
yeah but what the [ __ ] did i want to
talk to you about oh you know what i'm
off the cigars god damn it that last
email shamed me
the [ __ ] get off the pot
that's all i need all i need is a little
bit of shame and know that more than one
person is noticing this
and just the the embarrassment of it
i can just walk away from them
so
so here i sit
i smoke my last
i can't say one i smoked three on super
bowl sunday but two of them were nubs so
i count that as one cigar so i smoked
two cigars on sunday it is now wednesday
okay and uh
all i need to do
is go
another seven days and then i'll be ten
days in
and then i don't think about him anymore
then i should be good
then i should be good for the final time
we have a little humor door down at the
uh
one of these places around the corner
there and i'm just going to grab my last
little fistful of them put them in there
walk the [ __ ] away
i've decided i started playing guitar
again
um
i'll do that instead
you know
instead of sitting
and being
you know against the wall
at a party
you know what if i got off that wall and
picked up a guitar and be all suddenly
became
the life of the party
the focal point
hey bill do you know any peter paul and
mary like a bridge over troubled water
[ __ ] stairway to heaven
you know yeah i just realized i'm so old
now if i played popular songs
from my childhood young people would be
looking at me like i showed like who's
the old guy at the party and it'd be
like if i picked up like a clarinet and
started playing
like benny goodman
boo boo
i literally think that like
i think that that has now become because
i saw like you know i started watching
some guitar videos
i actually found one that has a really
cool exercise a couple of exercises
guitar theory and all that so like the
fretboard actually makes sense i'm like
wow i never did this i just always
played by ear
which i think is a good thing to appoint
like i'm a big believer you should you
should have as many [ __ ]
you know clubs in the bag as humanly
possible
you got your drivers you got your irons
you got your putters right you're
playing from your heart and soul but
every once in a while you need to go
between your ears to figure out why some
[ __ ] isn't working out
you know
don't do that man don't be thinking when
you're playing man
well you don't think when you're playing
man you sit down and you learn the stuff
and then you let it go and then just let
it naturally work in but isn't that
that's kind of like thinking man i don't
want to be thinking man
i don't want to be thinking when i'm
playing man i just want to be feeling
man
isn't it really you went to school and
got your ass kicked so anytime you see a
piece of paper with information on it it
takes you back to that little boy that
knew he was going back to summer school
just baby step your way in
you know
i think it's high time that musicians
learn how to read music again you know
some of the greatest musicians out there
could not read a lick of music a note of
music
oh really well i've been on youtube also
okay you mean the geniuses
geniuses geniuses geniuses
um
i don't know if i can do anything in the
last third of my life i would like to
bring the oboe back into [ __ ] popular
culture
you know when was the last time
i think that's why guitar fell out of
favor everybody just [ __ ] played the
thing and there were just no riffs left
you know what what the [ __ ] were you
supposed to do
meanwhile there's the oboe you know
like the fat chick on prom night like
hey pick me you know
i'll go home with somebody i got a hell
of a personality
you know i've actually learned how to
interact with other people
because i wasn't you know blessed with
what society
the standards of society's beauty beauty
um
oh man i'll tell you oh jesus
last night
um
was it last night i don't even remember
anymore
oh man just these two [ __ ]
i got to get the lovely nia on here at
some point
at some point the lovely near we got to
have our two different takes
on uh on what we saw last night we had a
great meal we went out for celebrate
valentine's day celebrating our
relationship
we do it you know
usually on the 17th 18th of some
[ __ ] like that
the last thing you do is i've been
saying for years is you don't go out on
the 14th that is a rookie [ __ ] move
it's like buying christmas gifts before
christmas
you don't
you tell your children on christmas
morning that they were too naughty and
santa claus doesn't love them anymore
and you let him cry for three days and
you go out and take advantage of the
post
christmas specials
and then you come home and say guys
i know you're real sad because santa
claus doesn't love you anymore but guess
who still loves you
your dad right and then they love you
and they're like [ __ ] santa claus
right
and it's a way to get yourself back into
like a good standing with them
these are just ideas people you don't
have to take all of them what i do is i
just you know i nudge i'm a nudger i
just sort of nudge you in a direction
and if you know you can take it you can
leave it however that [ __ ] cliche
you're in a safe space speak ghost
um
anyway
i've been working my [ __ ] ass off uh
you know and i'm gonna go run my hour
this week i gotta run my ry do this
[ __ ] acting gig
oh billy [ __ ] bill's getting his
[ __ ] revenge body back
although last night you know i did some
damage
we took a couple of waves broadside last
night but um
you know i'm right back on it
i'm right back on it now i mean i'm like
like
i'm literally like
i don't drink now
i quit smoking
i don't do drugs
unless i'm on vacation with my wife and
my kids aren't there
and even then it's the happier ones
you know we eat mushrooms
[ __ ] vaping you know smelling
household products under the sink you
know
personally i like the pine salt lemon
fresh if i'm gonna huff i really like
that
you know gives me a high and it reminds
me to clean the kitchen and at that
point i feel have the i have the energy
you know
you know i think huffing if it's done
right
is that still a thing
i mean jesus christ
the one good thing about huffing is like
every kitchen becomes like an open bar
you know you're just dropping in like
the wacky next door neighbor hey how's
it going
[Laughter]
you know pedophiles hang around schools
do huffers become plumbers so they can
always be underneath the sink near the
household products
you know you just hear them underneath
it
is everything all right under there
yeah man
almost got it fixed
um
huffing
jesus christ
if there's any can there be a greater
sign that the world is such a painful
place that people need to escape it
that you'd literally just like hey
there's some bleach let me take a big
[ __ ] whiff of that
wait isn't that how you cure covet
i don't know i have so much
misinformation in my head wasn't that
what you were supposed to do at some
point
did you take the
the bleach or the household cleaner and
rub it on your skin like uh
the clear
where you could lie to yourself that you
weren't on steroids
um
yeah i think that's what it was
i have no idea but uh guess what
california is lifting the mast ban la's
gonna hang in there for a little while
longer because we're more densely
populated
but
uh i can't wait for that day because i
got to be honest with you now that i got
the now that i got the vid
or the kovi or whatever the cool kids
the djs call it
um now that i've had it i feel like
invincible because i have the antibodies
and i'm starting to act like those
[ __ ] anti-master babies i'm not
wearing one into a store man i will
never get over that i will never get
over what [ __ ] babies so many adults
acted like you know and this is coming
from somebody who's uh you know
i mean i'm all about childish behavior
and not taking
account for your own actions
[Music]
quarantine meow stay six feet apart now
wear a mask now here's a vaccine now
[Laughter]
ah they all should have been wearing
diapers
um
whatever but in the end you know what's
funny in the end is everybody like
themselves will think that they did the
right thing
i did the right thing i listened to the
news
i listened
to no i listened to
people who told me what was on the news
and i did that
and i'll tell you i got away with it for
a long time um
anyway so uh
yeah so i i just you know what sucks is
i usually talk about what's going on in
my life but i can't talk about what's
going on my life professionally because
you know when you do these acting gigs
you're not allowed to talk about
anything
if you talk about anything they [ __ ]
hunt you down
you know
and and they put two in the back of your
head you ever seen that what's what's
the name of that that uh liev shriver
you know you come near my family i'll
[ __ ] kill you that show
you went to an audition and uh you were
five minutes late so the agent sent me
out here to [ __ ] kill you
what show is
that hey uh you were uh
up near the hollywood sign last night
one of the letters went out so now i
gotta [ __ ] kill you
ray donovan
ray
donovan hey you got a prostitute last
night and uh she died so uh now i gotta
hide you
uh oh hang on a second i gotta [ __ ]
kill you
um
[Laughter]
i am making fun of a show i've never
watched i'm just i'm i'm going based on
i'm sure it's fantastic okay i'm just
[ __ ] around here people because i
cannot
you know
i can't talk about what's going on my
life and then i gotta wait till my wife
is on the pub my wife i have to wait
till she's on the podcast so that i can
talk about
um
you know
what we encountered last night so we can
get both of our
our takes on it i will tell you this i
saw west side story
the steven spielberg version of it the
new one was [ __ ] amazing did i tell
you that i saw that yeah marie i just
met a girl named maria all of these
songs
i'm going to a [ __ ] deli all these
songs that i heard all through my life
and i never knew like comedians
it was like i never saw uh willy wonka
in the chocolate factory never saw it
but i knew all the songs because i'd
gone to comedy clubs and then all of a
sudden oh my god the oompa loompas
i had no idea and i also had no idea
what a [ __ ]
dark they killed that fat kid they
drowned him in chocolate
spoiler alert
i kind of loved it
i think that's what's wrong with this
country man can you imagine if that's
how they thinned out the population
they just started putting those hershey
parks
you know in every major city
and all the fatties that showed up right
it's like
they put like a chocolate jesus
above the chocolate pool so everybody
has to kneel down and as you kneel down
and rest your elbows on the uh the the
low chocolate wall
and you're on your knees and then
everybody has to like baptize themselves
by dunking their heads into the
chocolate
and no drinking because jesus will know
if you drank right when they go to do
that
the floor lifts up and just sends them
over
and that's it
and then they all die
their perfect death right death by
chocolate isn't that what they those
chocolate lovers love i'm sitting here
acting like i don't love a dessert that
i don't bake
you know what i mean that i didn't eat
46 000 ice cream sandwiches during the
pandemic i literally kept this [ __ ]
ice cream sandwich
a lot like that company going
like i bet in southern california like i
don't know what's going on out there but
our sales are [ __ ]
up eight percent
if their sales were up eight percent
during the pandemic i would say that i
was at least six percent of that i'm
taking credit for six percent of that
i almost got to the point one night i
ate two of them and i just i just
couldn't uh
the shame i felt as i started to walk
down the stairs
you know in my pajamas i'm a big pajamas
guy
once you have kids you got to have
pajamas on i'm also a big believer that
your children should never ever see you
naked ever
ever
you know you lock the bathroom door when
you're taking a shower so they don't
accidentally walk in you lock the
bathroom door when you're going to the
bathroom that's it
that's it i am a
non-entity when it comes to that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] hippie [ __ ] of like yeah
man you know it's the anatomy don't
don't [ __ ] you know
don't make it weird oh i'm the one
making it weird
i'm sitting over here with clothes on
always
always
always
that is it
that is a wrap so anyway so when you're
going downstairs
out of everything i've said in the
podcast that's the one that is not a
joke i really believe that your kids
should should just never
i think it's okay with the mother or
maybe not not for the son no it's just
bad
yeah
bad
and what kills me is all of us as kids
had that moment of ah
right
why would you do that
it's so easily avoided
you put on some pajamas
[Laughter]
why would you walk around naked
um
anyway
so
i was walking downstairs to get my
second
ice cream sandwich and my wife's going
where are you going
wait don't do it i'm just like can you
just leave me alone all right i'm
[ __ ] depressed i lost all my road
gigs for the year
you know
this is like the pope of greenwich
village
you know what are you worried about
charlie you ain't got no job to wear a
suit too what'd you say
no say what you just said i just said
you know why are you worried about
yourself you ain't got no job to wear it
to that was my [ __ ] when i was walking
why do i care about being in shape i
ain't got no [ __ ] show to go do
um
oh and did i pay for the ah man i paid
for it the next time i finally got on
the scale six months later
you know my wife had to rent a
one of those little baby cranes you know
those little bobcat [ __ ] front end
loaders she had one of those and i got
into the bucket
and she uh she dropped me down onto the
way i believe it was a cattle scale
and i was just freckled and fat and
pasty and i just look like a [ __ ] you
know a gingered snowman
um
i mean that was a [ __ ] mess
you know
and this is where i don't fall in line
with today's generation because at that
point what i was supposed to do is look
in the mirror and love myself
and say that i was a hero
and that there was no difference between
me and those brave men that stormed the
beaches of normandy
you know they fought the nazis in
fascism
and
i had some ice cream sandwiches and i
really failed to see the difference
you know
in a lot of ways i feel like i was
braver because mine was a slower death
[Laughter]
oh god someone will take that seriously
are you trying to say that eating ice
cream
is not is the same as storming the
beaches of normandy
i'm the new comedy fan
what i like to do with comedy is take it
literally
literally i'll tell you there is a world
you know if we have another pandemic
right if there's a new coven
right because god knows hollywood loves
to reboot and i think the cia is the
same way
you know like i think this was an
experiment
this one
you know they came up with the usual
story uh
somebody from another race [ __ ] a
monkey and you know
and now we're all suffering so it gave
enough mouth breathers you know
something to hate right or ate a monkey
or some [ __ ]
and i think i think that we passed the
test
for mass extinction that the people at
the top want but i don't have a problem
with that either
i really don't i don't have a problem
with people at the top
enact mass extinction on all of us
because the reality is is that they're
the ones that kept us alive
you know
they're the ones that feed us
they're the ones that tell us what to
think and uh and we do it
and i know you're listening and you
probably think you're the guy thinking
outside the box
because you're on the internet you're
talking to the real people you're having
the real truth conversations
um i love when people think they're
having truthful conversations on the
internet like i'm getting down
to the truth of this and they're going
to enact some sort of [ __ ] change
while they discuss their plans publicly
out in the open on the internet
um
i mean why would you do that i mean back
in the day you know
when people would have like military
coups and [ __ ] they they didn't discuss
it in public and that's what you're
doing when you're on the [ __ ]
internet oh really bill is the internet
a public place for everyone we didn't
know that could you talk down to us more
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay i'm just a man
on the other side of an ice cream
sandwich addiction just trying
to figure out how he can pick up the
pieces of his life
um
anyway oh by the way uh
on that [ __ ] play with the bengals
got that you know with the rams got that
makeup call i remember yelling false
start some bengals fans showed me the
clip i didn't realize it was that bad
the [ __ ] rams
half the whole left side of their
offensive line
like three guys
went all at the same time before the
ball was snapped the ref somehow missed
that and then called a phantom holding
call
i'll tell you that's a rough one
that is a rough one
i mean i understand missing that face
mask that was the slickest [ __ ]
it's like he tapped him on the shoulder
he looked the other way because he the
way he moved his arm
it looked like he was just bringing in
fast motion because nobody saw that in
fast motion some do should be like i saw
it i got a 70 inch [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] uh whatever the plasma
you didn't see it nobody saw it
and the ref wasn't in a position to see
it it was a slick veteran move it was
also cheating and they also got away
with something there so um
but i'm just saying i just uh i'm not
saying that the rams didn't deserve a
makeup call they absolutely [ __ ] did
but uh
it made it seem like they were like this
is the play we're doing it on because
how do you miss
900 pounds of human beings false
starting at the same time as an nfl ref
in the super bowl i don't know i don't
want to start some [ __ ] but that's what
happened man
um
anyway oh look who it is everybody solo
stove
you know
nothing there's nothing quite like the
feeling of gathering around a warm fire
on a cool evening
what are you talking about how about
walking barefoot in your pajamas to go
downstairs at two o'clock in the morning
to get your second ice cream sandwich
that's a hell of a feeling solo stove
says they have a better feeling than
that
i mean if you're not buying a stove now
you're not an american
and a smokeless fire pit from solo
stoves makes your outdoor moments even
more memorable because instead of having
to constantly dodge campfire fumes you
can sit back relax and actually enjoy
the fire and right now you can get a
great deal on a solo stove fire pit
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit solo stove fire pits if you
don't know what this is it's a solo
stove fire pit could they say that more
times in the copy solo stove fire pits
are brilliantly engineered made from
premium grade 304 stainless steel not
that 302 [ __ ] 304 stainless steel and a
360 degree airflow system that maximizes
efficiency while minimizing smoke
easy to light with a few bits of starter
your fire is blazing in minutes
perfectly portable take solo stove with
you on camping trips and moa shop now
and get up to 30 percent off fire pits
all month long and use promo code bur at
checkout to get an extra 10
off plus a lifetime warranty and free
30-day returns just go to solostove
s-o-l-o-s-t-o-v-e dot com and remember
you get 10 off when you use the promo
code burr b-u-r-r oh look who it is
everybody
it's helix alex
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you
know uh will be a perfect way
perfect for the way you sleep sorry i'm
reading text messages i'm gonna get a
[ __ ]
facetime here in a second and you know
everybody's unique doesn't mean you're
special it just means you don't look
like somebody else all right everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress great for
cooling down cooling you down if you
sleep hot gross
what do you got a [ __ ] murder in your
past mattresses great for a spinal
alignment i'd love that to prevent
morning aches and pains and even
a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers the big boys like old freckles
here with his [ __ ] ice cream sandwich
addiction
it wasn't even the eating the ice cream
sandwich it was the sound of the plastic
opening it up that really that's where i
really would get excited that was
probably the height
of my heart rate
um helix has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine and as as a
go-to solution for improving sleep
wow
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors i like how they slap
chiropractors down just to remind them
you're not a doctor uh just go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix has
even has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away helix is offering up
to 200 off all orders mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
one for your head one for between your
knees you know to keep your spine
aligned
and for our listeners
wait helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helixsleep.com
h e l i x sleep.com
for up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
all right you know what i want to do
this summer i'm not going to be able to
do it because i'll be touring you know
what i really just want to do
i want to [ __ ]
i want to go back to massachusetts for
the whole summer
you know
and i want to work
local dates
and i just want to go to [ __ ] red sox
games
and hang out with my kids
you know
and get a steak and cheese
and some crab rangoon and an ice cream
sandwich i mean can can a man of a
certain age do that
and not smoke any any cigars right go
down the cape and sit in traffic going
over the bourne bridge
i i i need to do that again
you know maybe get a lake house dude up
in new hampshire [ __ ] lake
winnipesaukee dude you know go up there
water skiing [ __ ]
jet ski
watch out for the floating rocks
dude um
i would like to do that
i get on the other side of this this
acting [ __ ] um
you know
i you know i've done enough okay i i
think i've worked enough
i'm gonna i need more hawaiian shirts in
my [ __ ] wardrobe you know not saying
i'm going to hawaii
all right i'm just saying i want to be
in situations where
wearing a hawaiian shirt
is not even noticed
you know
because i'm on a dock or i'm on a little
boat
right
i'm just going for an old man walk
you know with the dog the size of my
prostate i mean
[Music]
why can't i do that
is that asking too much as an american
um i don't think it is all right and
with that guess what we had coming up
next guess what we have coming up next
we have the bet
do we have the bet mg oh the [ __ ]
football season's over i don't even know
if we do that anymore maybe we'll do it
for the march madness there might be
some gambling talk here there might not
be um i usually do the intro and then i
come back with and i'll be all right
that was the better mgm segment with the
great paul verzi
um and now listen to some music
picked out by the always wonderful
andrew themilis
and
then we got a bonus
uh episode of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast uh that is it
that is the thursday podcast i hope you
guys have a great weekend
i hope you guys have fun
hope you enjoy one another don't take
life for granted
and uh yeah let's uh you know i feel
like we're coming out of the pandemic
cove it's just a cold now right
it's finally just a cold and a sore
throat i believe
at least that was my experience with
that was my [ __ ] experience from day
one shut up
shut up colds don't kill [ __ ] half a
million goddamn people all right well
ever meet many [ __ ] people how many
people die to covet
let's look that up here for a second
let's see here
all right
how many people
died from covet
worldwide what do you guys say i say 1.2
million
and the number is
5.84 million oh i was way under looks
like i'm not winning the death showcase
showdown
there was 450 15 million cases of it
and 5.84 million of those people died
now let's see
how many people died from
the common
cold worldwide
up to 650 000 people die of respiratory
diseases that's not it
can you die from the common cold
disease bureau climate change indicated
all right
i don't know
you know what i think if you sneezed
really hard and you were near some
formica and you hit your head maybe and
then you came back and hit the back of
your head and then fell down a flight of
stairs
and uh
i don't know
and then rolled into a pit of [ __ ]
murderers maybe then you could die i
don't i don't know how it [ __ ] works
all right that's the podcast everybody
if you're sitting here thinking what did
i just listen to i didn't learn a
[ __ ] thing
that was a complete waste of time that
is the entire purpose
of this podcast and i feel like i've
reached my goal all right that's it i'll
talk to you guys later have a great
weekend you can't
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday february 17
2014 how's it going how are you are you
enjoying this podcast so far i'll tell
you if you're listening to it on monday
monday the 17th i am actually
i'm in the [ __ ] air
that's why the podcast is out um as you
guys like to think early
or on time i should say it's early in my
world
all right it's early
um
yeah i'm on my way back to uh back to
the east coast to do a wonderful run of
shows
starting tuesday night
with the second annual patrice o'neal
comedy benefit
all money
after the expenses of course
we do have to rent the place else after
we pay back for renting out the [ __ ]
barn
yeah all monies goes to uh basically all
the people that uh were in patrice's
life that he was supporting
you know his mom his wife and on you
know step daughter and all that stuff
so it's a wonderful thing
um if you didn't get tickets uh we're
gonna do it again next year we're gonna
do it every year and i know a lot of
people like why don't you have a [ __ ]
donation button online because i'm
learning about this [ __ ]
i'm learning okay eventually every year
it'll get bigger maybe we can do two
shows one year i don't know okay
i'm new
to the benefit thing i hope i don't have
to do another benefit for anybody else
that i know and love all right so there
you go that's those are your those are
the answers to your questions
and i know that a bunch of people are
going to try to be helpful and show me
how to set something up through uh you
know i'm trying to raise money for my
buddies you know loved ones
dot com or whatever i'm not gonna be
able to figure it out
all right i am
i am anti-technology unless
it is trying to uh save
people's lives
or the lives of animals nature i don't
mind that stuff but as far as all these
[ __ ] apps
you can stick them in a ball
turn them up sideways and shove it
straight up your candy no sorry i had a
wrestling [ __ ] flashback
dude i just was uh trying to check in
for my flight that's all i was doing
just an old
freckled [ __ ] on the computer all i want
to do is check in
all i want to do
is romo zum zul all i want to do is find
what airline i'm flying
it's all when does it leave
oh yeah is that when it leaves well i'll
be sure to be there before it takes off
all right so what do i get i get some
[ __ ] email
from these goddamn [ __ ]
and i can't access by itinerary
unless i sign up for their app
trip case
these [ __ ] just emailed me back
you're almost there verify your email
with trip case go [ __ ] yourself
dude so i basically i can't view
when my plane takes off or lands because
now i have to download
a [ __ ] app
to say
you know eastern airlines leaves
your flight leaves at [ __ ] 11 in the
morning and arrives at 7 pm
why do i need
an application for that can somebody
from this new world of fat children
where you don't go outside
and you play your video games and you
sext one another in the [ __ ] sixth
grade can one of you no not not at all
let's get out of that [ __ ] world can
somebody of age
[ __ ] tell me
why in god's name i would need
this i don't like the [ __ ] word app
download our app
do you have our app
i literally i have to just just to find
out when my [ __ ] plane takes off i
had to [ __ ] download this thing they
wanted my they wanted me to to sign in
with my email and my password so now the
[ __ ] over there have the [ __ ]
password to my email
like i i'm i don't i don't understand
that
why do i need a password how do i know
everybody at trip case
is is is on the [ __ ] level
you know if you're not trying to figure
out how to grow a kidney in a dish like
okay and you're not out there trying to
[ __ ] prolong the life of a walrus
you know
i guess i'm guilty of it too
what do i do what do i do to hurt the
environment what just what do i do i
take 40 000 flights a year
i'm back to using pam instead of putting
butter
in the skillets
you know because my wife wore me down i
don't understand why you just don't use
pam
you know
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] up the ozone layer you
know i try to be like that that doesn't
that doesn't work that doesn't work when
you live with somebody
you know at some point you just got to
be like all right you know
i'm sure there'll be plenty of ozone
left for my life
as we sit here in the middle of this
heat wave
um
anyways
so i had to just
bug somebody
who's on in the middle of our weekend to
tell her can you just copy and paste
what airline i'm on where i'm going and
when can you do that so i don't have to
go to trip case
and download their [ __ ] app
jesus wait is it really the fault of the
people at trip case hey god bless them
you know what they could have gone and
[ __ ] worked for somebody else but no
they all sat together and they sold
their skateboards and then they made
this company goddamn it they're trying
to make their money what else they
supposed to do we don't make anything
else in this country
all right we basically we plant and grow
weed and we create apps that's what we
do in this country and in the middle of
it we eat a lot of bugles
okay this is from the people outside of
america
all right if you haven't been here and
other than that we make great music and
great movies that you guys all then go
and rip off your bunch of [ __ ] hacks
jesus christ has there been any [ __ ]
original programming
that didn't come out of america
i mean it's absolutely ridiculous
i mean the failed attempt of ricky
gervais and those guys who did the
original office like they didn't know
that we had the follow-up in development
come on england
you're better than that
you're [ __ ] better than that you went
from an empire to that
ripping off our shows that we haven't
put out yet but you know we're putting
them out [ __ ] you with your cup of tea
who's this oh you hear that new stupid
[ __ ] ring
right like i'm on an island but i'm not
um oh shut up how do you get to the stop
i i had to download the new [ __ ]
whatever because my phone stopped
working
the latest
it's like the [ __ ] iphone work fine
it's unbelievable i stand on a [ __ ]
mountain i can talk to somebody
i haven't froze to death yet why do i
need it to be better
why does it have to be bad
i don't wanna i don't wanna update
anything else anymore okay i'm done
updating i'm done with apps i'm done
with all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] like i
said unless it literally
is affecting
my ability
to live
a healthy [ __ ] life i don't give a
[ __ ] about your app
[Music]
do you brush your teeth have you
downloaded our app
it'll really show you how to get in
between your teeth
really the [ __ ] dentist can't tell me
that
you know
what what are you supposed to do all the
factories left
back in the day you'd be in some auto
auto worker place making a [ __ ]
fender
oh jesus
oh hello mr boy welcome to your cell
phone
all right
let's just shut this off
you know what i like about it it's
actually
weirdly upbeat which i think goes along
with my [ __ ] you know balances out
my [ __ ] behavior
um
speaking of the dentist
i went to the dentist this week
whatever sat in the [ __ ] chair and i
got what's known as a deep
cleaning you know like six months ago or
whatever july was what's that eight come
on eggheads how do you look at the
calendar i'm sure it's in some beautiful
mind way
well it's 472 daily
um
it actually wouldn't be that's over a
year 365 days in a year really
all right anyways um
yeah so i was supposed to get this i
don't know i got my teeth cleaned uh
like i don't know about a year ago this
time and then i went back to the dentist
over the [ __ ] summer
dude when you put your [ __ ] boat in
the water
come over there with a pack of [ __ ]
cores light dude
scrape it off the [ __ ] particles
um
and i guess on my last trip to [ __ ]
the dentist
to [ __ ] the dentist um
i agreed to get this deep cleaning deep
cleaning
ron jeremy stars in deep
cleaning
i um i agreed to have this [ __ ] thing
done and uh you know i don't listen to
people
all right i don't i look i'm sort of
looking at you and i'm nodding
yeah yeah yeah sounds good sounds good
just stop talking leave me i want to get
out of here
so
i come back in july
and rather than the lady
who cleans my teeth there's some dude
sitting there with his smock on and he
goes all right do you want us to numb
you up
uh we gotta numb you up is what he said
and i went well what what we i thought i
was just here to get a cleaning what are
you pulling teeth out he goes no
you said last time that you wanted to
come in for
a
deep cleaning right and i was just like
all right well look how long is this
going to take you said like 90 minutes
i'm like i don't have time for that [ __ ]
i thought this was gonna be like 45 i
didn't say [ __ ] but i said listen i i
you know
i have other stuff to do i have drums to
play i might go play hockey i might go
fly a kite because i'm a 45 year old
child
i have things
that i have to get to
so they go all right well cool man we're
not trying to hassle you man
just reschedule and i said fi you got it
you got it dr smocky smock and i'll see
you later that tootsie lady and i walked
out
and i've been trying to get back
to do it and i just you know i traveled
all over the place i got married all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] happened so now
now i finally go in
for for the thing
i go and i say all right let's do this
so i go okay so you got to numb me up
and he said well it's optional
i go what do you mean it's optional well
some people you know they get numbed up
other people don't i'm taking basically
a drilly thing and i'm going in between
your teeth and it can kind of irritate
your gums
and blah blah blah and i said well do i
need to get numbed up and he said well
personally i don't do it
so i say i will [ __ ] it let's let's see
how it feels
let's see how it feels right so
i gotta tell you this
unless you have like you know your teeth
are sensitive to cold you have like a
little bit of a nerve involvement
um i'll give you a pass on that but
people get numbed up for that you know
what
i'm not trying to talk [ __ ] here but
you're a bunch of [ __ ]
was it irritating yes
was it something i would like to be
feeling every day every moment of the
waking day no
but was i screaming bloody murder not at
all it was fine
you know it was great when i walked out
i didn't my face wasn't numb
you know
yeah like that bill cosby bit
i'm trying to give you hey i saw bill
cosby this week
i saw him he was walking right down the
street now i saw him uh out at the uh
pasadena
civic center playhouse whatever they
called it and uh it was unbelievable
uh the lovely nia took me there for
valentine's day
took me out um
first of all that's the first time i've
been out on valentine's day
in years
because knee is cool as [ __ ]
and i just said listen this is stupid
this is stupid to go out on this night
you guys know this deal maybe there's
somebody new
somebody from oshie
uh not oshie i'm thinking about who
scored all the goals there
what the [ __ ]
ah christ i can't so she
in sochi
right hey how about a [ __ ] round of
applause for bob costas
you know toughen it out jesus christ
putting the glasses on every day that
that that infection got worse in his eye
then it jumped to his other eye they
just kept pulling the camera back
started up with a they had like a
[ __ ] three-quarter shot by the end of
it he was like on the other side of the
studio they were pulled back so far and
finally just said i was literally by the
last night i saw him i was just like
dude he should just go home
just [ __ ] just say [ __ ] it you know i
what you're not gonna call me for the
next olympics
matt lauer is gonna come in here and
kill it so hard that you're not gonna
hire bob [ __ ] costus
i've been around since the aba
go [ __ ] yourselves i'll see you guys in
two years and then he finally left i
think he left good for him
good for him but he toughed it out man
he tought it out so anyways
um
so i'm on my way to uh
over to pasadena which is where uh
dr cosby
showed my respect here
was performing and uh dude i got a suit
and tie on everything it's it's obvious
because it's valentine's day three
reasons valentine's day i'm seeing you
know out of respect for nia and then
also you know i'm seeing cosby
and then lastly i buy these [ __ ]
suits and i never wear
i wear them once
put a gun to my head and i do five
minutes on a talk show hope i don't fall
off the stage
you know which is the only way anybody's
gonna see your set on a [ __ ] talk
show now if you do stand up
if you kill nobody sees it if you fall
off the stage and your dick falls out of
your pants it's going to get 100 million
hits so anyways i have all these these
suits
from my numerous tv appearances um
[Music]
and uh i'm like i gotta wear these
[ __ ] so i was driving over
there
and uh i could not believe the traffic
and i can't believe
oh i don't believe
i don't believe that couples put
themselves through that [ __ ] why would
you do that
don't do that to yourselves
okay there's a couple of and i know you
got what you guys are saying like bill
you [ __ ] say this every week well
[ __ ] you i saw the traffic out there
obviously nobody's listening to me what
you guys can like i'll tell it this way
because you guys already know this [ __ ]
can can you tell other people
i would there wasn't you know if i can
accomplish anything in my life if i
could just sabotage
that [ __ ] holiday
there's got to be like
i was just going to say the anti-holiday
valentine's day then that becomes a
[ __ ] crowded mess okay there's a
number
of gatherings that you do not have to
participate in and you can immediately
without making a dollar more an hour
increase
the quality of your life
all right you don't need to go to super
bowl parties
i already told you how to get through
that
now valentine's day you don't have to
[ __ ] go out i already told you how to
do that st patrick's day stupid
[ __ ]
stupid
go out on the 16th
go out on the 16th i know you think what
about the 18th well everybody's yacked
in the bar and no matter how much clorox
they use you're still smelling that
stomach acid okay sorry ladies who are
listening to this you go out on the 16th
all right unless the 16th to friday
night because then everybody's going to
be drinking all weekend whatever you do
if that's the case go out on the
wednesdays you know
that's [ __ ] dumb
they don't even have st patrick's day in
ireland
they don't even know who the guy is they
don't even wear green in ireland you
think everybody's over there with an
irish sweater on cutting into some soap
after they jumped off a horse to let you
know how to wash your [ __ ] taint
they're not
they're going to work over there dressed
like coach on cheers and they're going
into their [ __ ] cubicles all right
and they're putting their hands in their
keyboards and between their knees they
got themselves a flask all right and
that's how you celebrate st patrick's
day
um
anyways i'm on my [ __ ] soapbox this
week let me uh let me uh i'll read a
little bit of advertising there
and uh
and then then i'll
i'll tell you the bill cosby story oh by
the way no more uh nature's box on this
podcast evidently they're a bunch of
babies
they took their little snacks and of
course they're babies they give out
snacks
so i will not be saying the name of
their company anymore from here on out
they will just be known by their new
nickname the tree [ __ ] all right
alliteration has nature all right
i'm suggesting some sort of female
element i like it
um all right dollar shave club dude
for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality raises right to your door
not only does it save you
personally a ton of cash it saves you
from trudging to the drugstore for a
pack of blades i always get stuck behind
that person who just realized they [ __ ]
their pants and they don't have the
decency to walk out of the store you
know it's like they don't understand a
toilet exists sorry people i'm out of
examples
but now with dollar shave club for just
a couple of bucks a month amazing
quality razor blades are delivered right
to your door that's right
in case you said is that correct i just
said that's right
like i'm in your room with you no more
wasting time and no more getting hit up
for 20 bucks every time you buy razors
like they're not a piece of crap all
right everybody here meaning me is
getting that dollar shave club blades
and you know what you should too if you
wanna
and here's a great idea try replacing
your old shaving cream with dr
from dollarshaveclub.com trust me your
face will thank you later if it could
speak don't waste time at the drugstore
behind the lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub dot com forward slash
burr or go to billboard.com and click on
the dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high save time shave money go to
dollarshaveclub.com there we go note
please personalize areas highlighted in
yellow
i did with the [ __ ] in the pants story
it's about as personal as it gets
all right stamps.com
oh my god stamps.com like the willy
stargill of this lineup in its 20th
season stamps.com everybody you've
probably heard
the cost of a stamp just went up to 49
cents i'm sure you were in a bar
in the middle of hanging out with your
friends and all of a sudden somebody had
to have said hey did you hear
stamps went up to 49 cents
um
anyways
if you haven't who cares there's
stamps.com with stamps.com you'll pay
less for postage
uh you pay less than you want to pay at
the post office
for first class mail priority priority
express mail packages and moa stamps.com
is easy to use and convenient you can
buy and print discounted stamps shipping
labels and more using your own computer
and printer not only will it save you
money with with stamps not only will you
save money with stamps.com by not paying
full price for postage you'll save
valuable time to because you don't have
to go to the post office anymore okay if
you can't figure it out you can do it
right at home standing in your
underwears
stamp.coms always stamps.com always
keeps the rates up to date so you get
the exact postage you need every time
right from your desk never go to the
post office again i absolutely love this
product
i use stamps.com anytime i send out my
dvds my posters whatever i'm selling
after my shows
i'm a [ __ ] if i can figure it out you
can too however right now use my last
name bur b-u-r-r for this special offer
no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
okay
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur bur that
stamps dot com enter bur
b u
double r
all right well let's talk about the
cause
all right
first thing i get into uh i pull up to
the theater right
and uh you know it's valentine's day
there's a bunch of [ __ ] animals out
there and i'm like i don't want to try
to find the parking garage
i don't know where it is
and then they i see valet and i'm like
oh valet [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it i'm gonna valet a prius
isn't you know a 2008 prius with a bird
[ __ ] stain
the likes of which i haven't seen since
owning the car right on the windshield
i'm pulling up and i'm valeting it and
right as i pulled up i started thinking
well this is like a 3000 seater
what if half the crowd does this how
long am i going to be waiting and i was
just like oh [ __ ] it
my feet hurt i'm valeting so i valet
i walk into the theater
and uh you know tickets work
i i ask for no duels they don't have any
so i get a [ __ ] water
and i get some wine for my wife right so
we go into the theater beautiful theater
lovely theater
made in the 1930s right and we go in
there and uh first thing i do is look at
the stage it's the coolest thing ever
it's like there's this little apartment
up there for bill cosby he has like a
little four by four
rug oriental rug
all right no offense to the orient
and uh he has a chair and then next to
it he has a little like nightstand a
little table
with this little
i don't know what little cooler
that has all his drinks in it
and then he has his little headset thing
it's the coolest thing ever
and um
so we're sitting there it's supposed to
start at eight o'clock
and right at eight on the nose
no opening act no intro
he just walks out on stage
i was actually looking down i don't know
what the hell i was doing
and the only reason i knew he was
had walked out on stage is because the
crowd started cheering
and of course everybody stood up and all
that type of stuff and he went over and
he put on his little uh
his little headset thing that's like
see-through like john bonham's vista
light kit
and uh so you don't even notice that he
puts that thing on and then it's like
he's sitting right next to you
and the guy and literally he sits down
and kills for two and a half hours
two and a half hours he's 76 years old
77 this year two and a half hours
absolutely destroys his first like bit
took a half hour
he was talking about valentine's day and
how you got it all the pressure to get
you know uh you know the
the woman something and all you get is a
card
starts with that premise
and then just
goes i don't know where he went
30 minutes later he brings it back to
that
to a thunderous applause break
and i looked over at my wife and i go
that's his first joke
half hour in
so he did two and a half hours so i
guess that's like what he did five jokes
[Laughter]
it was uh
it was amazing and uh what i don't know
i i never seen him
live like just do a full set and get to
sit in the crowd and it was um
an unbelievable honor it was the best
valentine's day gift i've ever got
and she's she always gives me something
nice and but that was the best and um
it's definitely a bucket list thing and
just to be able to sit there
in the crowd and watch him do his thing
as i've tried to do what he's done for
22 years to have that perspective to
have the perspective as a as a as a fan
and an audience member like it was
working on like five different levels it
was it was awesome
and uh and then i walked out and i ran
into like three other comics
you know that i knew and we're all
geeking out two and a half hours you
[ __ ] believe that i've never done two
and a half hours my life got 76 it was
awesome and then i walked out there and
there must have been
900 people waiting for their valid cars
[Laughter]
so i just stood there
up by the theater with a couple other
comics
and we just sat around just giving each
other [ __ ] and talking about the
business and all that and then just kept
going back to how amazing bill cosby was
so if you get a chance
it's really cool he's also you know he
just put out that special so he's
working on some new materials so i got
to see that
i got to see bill cosby workshopping
material and you know
you know you see which ones
that are already
monster bits and then you see the other
ones that are on their way it was
i got the hiccups though it was it was
it was amazing so um
you know definitely if you if there's
very few masters out there that you can
go watch them live
creating live i i highly recommend going
out and uh
and seeing uh bill cosby man it was
awesome it was awesome and i got to wear
a suit
you know so it was a [ __ ] two-four
um
all right oh this is something i have to
mention hey everybody do you like buying
[ __ ] off my website well i got some new
stuff um i did a uh
a tour at the end of last year right
before my european tour
um
oh i did that run of dates where i
played the beacon in new york city i
played constitution hall in dc and then
i played tower theater three absolutely
legendary venues i still can't believe i
got to perform there so as always thank
you to everybody who came out
um
i have a limited amount of posters left
over from that tour
and they will be going on sale i believe
like on wednesday of this week there's
like 300 left
um
it's first come first serve
the posters are 20 inches tall and 16
inches wide they will arrive in a
shipping tube and reading all this stuff
and you know what
i am and and in the effort to get these
things out of my house
and to give you guys more incentive i i
autographed each one of them
i sat at my kitchen table and
painstakingly autographed
300 posters
it must have taken me
at least 17 minutes my wrist is still
sore
i live a very difficult life as an
artist whatever i have posters
autographed posters if you want them
they make a great gift at 20 bucks plus
shipping it's going to be autographed
you know and if you go to give it to
somebody and they don't like it you got
the empty tube to smash over their head
when you're done and then you pick up
the poster and you get it framed
yourself
not because you like me just because it
will always remind you of hitting that
person over the head
you know you know what's great about the
the poster tube is you get the release
like you [ __ ] smashed a bat over
somebody's head
without
having to get rid of a body afterwards
because it's just cardboard
you know
if i ran a prison i would allow
everybody to have a poster
tube
and be like enough with the shanks
people all right just hit each other
with cardboard if you break it don't
worry we'll make some more down the
office all right
everybody relax we'll get you some pot
cookies
you know
get you some porno everybody can rub one
out at the beginning of the day that way
nobody gets raped in the showers
okay
this this is this is a new kind of
prison
all right just everybody just [ __ ]
relax
all right look at him you're not getting
out so
i don't know why you want to sit here
fighting with each other when we all get
together maybe we'll write some songs
no
all right well you know it's it's it's
uh you know it's we'll work on it
enjoy your enjoy your tubes
daddy i took it too far with the this
one yeah i thought it did um anyways all
right let's let's get let's get on with
the uh the podcast here so um
i've been watching i've been missing all
the olympic hockey because it's coming
on at 4 30 in the morning and because i
haven't been drinking i've been falling
asleep
like the middle-aged man that i am like
i'm falling asleep every night like 9 30
10 o'clock
and i when i when i wake up
at like six in the morning where i could
at least watch the third period i guess
or the end of the third period but it
never dawns on me
because they just woke up
you know
this is what i have to do before i get
out of bed
um and if your feet are [ __ ] up
um you know i [ __ ] up my foot too i
got that plantar fasciitis in my bass
drum foot trying to get trying to play
good times bad times my technique i i
had poor technique
and i don't know how does anybody know
how to rehab that because every time i
run or do anything that exerts pushing
off with that foot it comes right back
but i'm able to kind of you know
roll a tennis ball under my foot and i'm
fine
but like when i get up in the morning if
i don't want to have problems
this is what i do
all right
i wake up i look at the ceiling
all right i look over my wife and i'm
like good she didn't leave me
all right the dog hears me stirring and
immediately
i hear her i hear her stretching
because she makes she makes this noise
she goes
then she stretches again and then i hear
her
dog is shaking as she [ __ ] shakes her
head for whatever goddamn reason
um
and all of that happens is i'm looking
at the ceiling
and before i take step number one if you
ever [ __ ] up your your whatever that
is there
underneath your foot that tendon if you
ever [ __ ] it up what really [ __ ] you
over it's that first step in the morning
all right i learned this from another
comedian who is a world champion
and this is basically what you do before
you get out of this is what i have to do
and i've never played organized sports
and this is just and i and i stretch
and i still you get to a certain [ __ ]
age like i literally throw out my back
sleeping i wake up like what what did i
do
was i lifting [ __ ] or sleepwalking
um
i basically i point my toes
at my knees
you try to do that pain point toes
towards your knees i'm doing it right
now and you hold it there for a good 10
20 second count
right
one mississippi two mississippi but you
say it in your head so you don't wake up
your significant other then
you point your toes
down at the the end of the bed
for another 10 20 seconds
you do that right so now you stretch the
bottom of your foot you stretch the tens
on the top of your foot and then
clockwise or counterclockwise
i know a lot of young people like jesus
christ what the [ __ ] well i got news for
you this day is coming in your life
all right it's called your late 30s
early 40s all right then what you do is
then you bring your feet to normal
position
standing side by side like those [ __ ]
jerk-offs that guard that thing over
there in london
and then you either go clockwise or
counterclockwise you just make big slow
circles
and then you go the other way a couple
times
then i get out of bed
and i gingerly walk no pun intended i
know i'm a redhead and i i i twinkle
told my way over to the bathroom
and i just make noise ah jesus christ i
curse and stuff as i'm walking over
there
and then that's it
and that's it and then i have to go
through the the beginning i gotta
stretch
this is just so i can walk my dog down
the [ __ ] street and not be in
traction
it's pathetic
it really makes me sad that
i used to wake up remember as a little
kid you just woke up
you woke up and one of your other
siblings just was like hey you want to
go outside and [ __ ] play but yeah you
just jumped out of bed and just ran down
the stairs
that [ __ ] cereal you just shoved the
[ __ ] you you just ran out the [ __ ]
door
you never stretched
ever you never threw out your back
you're jumping over [ __ ]
[ __ ] play fighting get into real
fights you were fine
you brand new right off the assembly
line
bran
[ __ ] new
then after a while i don't give a [ __ ]
no matter how much [ __ ] juices you
drink
i don't know what happens to your
attendants they just [ __ ] they shrink
up after a while
um all right i don't mean to depress you
guys um
you know my latest obsession is when it
comes to cars
like learning learning about cars and
that type of [ __ ] is i am absolutely
fascinated with differentials
i didn't know there was oil in there
all these years of owning cars i didn't
know that the oil was in there
and that you've got to change it when
should you change it every 30 to 50 000
miles i'm dying to [ __ ] change it i'm
dying to take that [ __ ] thing off the
back i've watched enough youtube videos
to know how to do it
um changing oil it's easy
you just gotta you just gotta get one of
those torque wrenches and know what
you're supposed to [ __ ] put the
screws back on to pounds per square
whatever the [ __ ] it is or is that air i
don't know [ __ ] you i can figure it out
but you know what sucks on my truck
the 68 f-100
um
that backing plate
that usually faces the back of the car
on mine it's on it faces the engine
it's on the other side
so the drive shaft is there with that
other [ __ ] thing and then there's
that so i would have to take off
all of that
and drain it out and i know what you
guys are thinking bill
for the love of [ __ ] god
don't do that to yourself
as much as you probably get a funny bit
out of it please do not do that i don't
know when the other people who just love
people the fried and shirts
or whatever the [ __ ] you say they'll be
like yeah bill give that a whirl see how
that happens
that's a [ __ ] scary thing to do
because that's not that's not a an
injury you can walk away from in other
words
you know what's weird at that point
is if is if
i did all that and i couldn't get that
[ __ ] back together i could still start
my truck up
and i could go through all the gears and
all of that [ __ ] well great i guess the
transmission fluid would be lincoln
leaking out if i took off the [ __ ]
would it if i took off the uh
was that called the drive shaft if i
took that [ __ ] thing off i'm gonna do
it
[ __ ] you i'm trying it i just i'm just
fascinated with the fact that i don't
think it's ever been changed in that
there's air in there
from
it was put together in march according
to the uh the number inside the door it
was put together in ontario
believe it or not ford had an ontario
plan or something like that in uh in
march of 1968
and somebody closed that [ __ ] up and
that air has been trapped in there and i
think it's high time i released it
i guess it's an ungodly [ __ ] smell
but um i've i posted this video before
um for people like me who don't know
[ __ ] about cars and are just starting to
learn
um it's a very intimidating part of the
car
and to actually
see the genius of how it [ __ ] works
i'm gonna post that video again because
i absolutely love it and i'll actually
show this guy from uh bleepin jeep
um youtube uh or is it bleepingjeep.com
he gets in there he changes the oil and
he does some other [ __ ] in there and
then then on youtube there'll be a bunch
of other [ __ ]
youtube videos we can actually look at
all the [ __ ] gears in there the
spider gears
the pinion gears all that [ __ ]
you know i watched this guy take an axle
off and all that tight with the little
[ __ ]
c clan whatever the [ __ ] it is i was
fascinating [ __ ] the balls
to go in that deep that's what i i just
have to respect it and speaking of
respect
even though i missed all the games i
watched the highlights i just saw the
the third period in the shoot out of the
uh usa russia game how about that
[ __ ] tj oh
sheeshy
uh tg tj oshie
basically he was just basically the our
[ __ ] shootout guy
we just kept sending him and he
delivered every time jonathan quick you
know what i loved about him scoring that
over is how he when the second he scored
the uh
the shootout goal
that had us beat the russians he
immediately turned around he pointed at
jonathan quick you know something
somebody else could have done when they
tipped a pass to a linebacker about a
month ago you know you can do that every
once in a while it's nice to see
somebody do that
um and phil kessel phil kessel's been
crushing it the former bruin and now
toronto maple leaf
who i will be seeing i will be going to
a a maple leaf game
and i'll also be going to a a canadian's
bruins game
when i'm up there and i can i can't
[ __ ] believe it i'm gonna see two
original six
home games and one against another
original six and the best [ __ ]
rivalry as far as i'm concerned
over the years you gotta say that you
know not discounting any of the great
detroit rivalries
and some of that [ __ ] out west um
or even the islanders and rangers or
flyers and penguins it's just a [ __ ]
great leak
um
anyways so that that tour is coming up
quick i have a week's worth of dates i'm
back here for like four days and then
i'm in canada man and i have not drank
for 20 days by the time you hear this 21
days
and i got to tell you something i am
[ __ ] miserable i'm not miserable but
i i miss it man
i really [ __ ] miss it i'm not gonna
lie
i don't need it
i don't need it i mean what do you
really need you know
did i need
to to buy another pair of socks i have
other socks you know but uh
i miss
i should have never broken up with it
i'll live with this regret for the rest
of my life no i'm basically
me and verzi are not drinking
until we get to canada once we get to
canada
it's hilarious right now i was talking
to him i said listen paul all right we
both haven't drank in a while
i've been going easy on the stoves
and um
you know it would be a shame
if in those 20 days we gave back
everything that we gained
and he's like oh yeah dude yeah yeah i
know i said yes listen i'm not saying
i'm not gonna drink
i'm not saying i'm not gonna smoke a
couple of cubans but let's just you know
let's try to
to manage
you know let's try maybe the first two
days we don't drink and then we go to
the [ __ ] maple leafs game we'll have
a couple of beers and and paul said yeah
yeah yeah and then we just start
laughing because we know what's going to
happen
we know what is going to happen
all right
it's going to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show so all i'm trying to do
is drop as much [ __ ] weight as i
possibly can and get into such great
shape
because i know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna
do
it's over
it's [ __ ] over i'm gonna do what
every one of you guys would do so don't
[ __ ] judge me i can't wait
i can't wait i wake up every day
you know i don't know
yeah i feel good but i don't i i don't
know
what am i supposed to do i have a porch
how am i not how do you not drink when
you have a porch
it's just a green i got a rocking chair
i'm i'm you know
it was easy to not drink
when i didn't have a poor i don't know
what it is about the porch i just get
out there and all of a sudden i i i want
to [ __ ]
i want a drink
[Music]
um
all right let me do a little more
advertising when i come back i'm going
to talk about my add and i want to thank
everybody who's been trying to help me
with it now that i finally agreed with
my wife that i have it all right
legalzoom.com
everybody
some things like starting a business or
protecting your family with a will
aren't like your other new year's
resolutions you can't afford to blow
them off
instead of less snacking and more
exercise put this stuff at the top of
your list legalzoom helps you
incorporate or form an llc with their
simple questionnaire starting at just 99
over 1 million entrepreneurs have done
it and 90 of customers recommend
legalzoom to friends and family you can
also create a will at just 69 bucks or
even a living trust quickly and easily
and get peace of mind and protection no
surprise fees no hassles man and no
headaches legalzoom step-by-step process
was created by a team of experts in law
and technology legalzoom is not not a
law firm but can connect you with the
third party attorney and provide you
with self-help services
from wills to business formations
um trademarks powers of attorney and
more go to legalzoom.com for even more
savings type in bur bu double r into the
referral box at checkout don't put
things off today that you need to do for
tomorrow go to legalzoom.com now and use
the discount code burr b-u-r-r that's
legalzoom.com discount code burr be
b-u-r-r all right you got to do that by
the way
by the way i'm actually in the process
of doing it right now making out a will
you gotta you gotta do it because if you
don't
you know who's gonna get your smoking
jacket the government um e-voice
e-voice
if you're a business owner
um wait you're a business owner but
automated phone systems and secretaries
are not in your budget just yet and
juggling incoming calls makes it makes
it hard to look like a professional
here's something that will dramatically
help you more
uh and make you wait a minute here's
something that will dramatically help
you make more money in 2014 e-voice
whether you're a business of one or 100
e-voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll-free number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks can't take a call no
problem e-voice will transcribe the
voicemail and email it right to you
never be caught off guard again and with
e-voice you can try it before you buy it
right now
just for my listeners you get a 60-day
trial
to e-voice for absolutely free go to
evoice.com and enter the promo code bill
b-i-l-l at checkout take charge of your
business and make more money in 2014 go
to evoice.com and enter bill at checkout
for your 60-day free free trial that's
evoice.com promo code
bill you know what's funny with those
reads i was actually thinking through
the first couple i was like i'm doing a
great job
and then all of a sudden that voice in
my head whatever you do don't [ __ ] it up
and of course you start [ __ ] it up
tj oshie doesn't think that [ __ ] phil
kessel doesn't think that [ __ ] that's
why he puts the biscuit in the basket
all right so i mentioned um add last
week that i've finally given in that i
[ __ ] have it brutally and um so
people sent me all these links and as
far as i can tell
other than trying harder to focus
you got to take some drugs man
um and i looked at the list of drugs
none of which i would ever ever in a
million years entertain putting myself
on
you know destroy your brain beat up your
liver but oh will you focus
be sitting there totally listening every
word as i got drool coming out of my
mouth
uh one other thing ritalin
was one of the things that they
suggested like who still suggests
ritalin
i've seen even i have seen the stories
okay with all the sports and [ __ ]
that i watch
um
well speaking of add and speaking of
shows that i love is anybody watching
true detective
please tell me you're watching true
detective and if you've seen all four
episodes i'm not gonna spoil anything
for anybody okay
i just have to wait for that person to
take their their hands away from their
ears i'm not gonna ruin anything
it's dangerous to drive like that stop
staring with your knees
um
i've seen all four episodes and uh
this past week's episode
certain people were going on and on
about the way it was shot
and i think that they actually which was
amazing but that
gem of a conversation
in the bar this week
i absolutely [ __ ] loved it i thought
it's very rare that i see
a scene
with both characters are arguing and i
feel like they're both 100 right they're
both 100 right in that scene
and uh it's just oh my god [ __ ]
matthew mcconaughey
jesus christ
crushing it
everybody is
reggie even that that prisoner guy
ready to do
reggie did this [ __ ] [ __ ] ready
to do i [ __ ] love that guy
that's my new show everybody
considering gas monkey there there i
know they were between
seasons
do you know how depressed i am when i
get through all of the fast and louds i
watch all of them like three times and
then i just have like my favorite ones
where they just have certain cars
um what are some of my favorite ones
i'll tell you i like the uh
so my favorite cars that they've done
was when they um
which one was the i would say the 55
ford that they made for uh mark cuban
that that one i just absolutely [ __ ]
what they did to that car painting it
all white
i absolutely in the interior that
[ __ ] car and the way it sounded then
they did another one
they did this 1950 rocket 88 where they
do this thing where
you know it's starting to rust but it's
not like debilitating rust and they just
put a clear coat over it so you got this
badass
mean looking car that you can lean up
against and underneath it everything's
[ __ ] brand new and it sounds like a
[ __ ] beast as they go down the road
they got the white wall tires that was
another one that i loved
um
what else i even liked that crazy
station wagon with that opened like a
clam shell
ah there's just been so many i don't
know
my favor and then of course though i've
already talked about this the one when
richard tried to sell the car back to
the people for 30 grand and they knew
what the [ __ ]
his brother comes in his brother wanted
30 grand and he busted him down to 18
grand and then his other brother comes
back and goes he shouldn't have sold the
car what do you want for it and richard
was like yeah i was taking like 30 grand
and the other guy's like hey [ __ ] head i
know what you paid for and then richard
just laughs
and then they settled for like 20 grand
he still made like 1500 bucks
i [ __ ] loved that show
i wish they'd do more motorcycles
um
anyways
plowing ahead so my new show
now that breaking bad's over
um is that show true detective uh get in
early so you don't feel overwhelmed like
i am with house of cards i know i have
to start watching that
just so many great shows shameless i
haven't watched one episode of that i
got a bunch of [ __ ] i have to get caught
up on but um true detective
i don't know if it can get better than
that right now man it's [ __ ] awesome
see but add helps me look at this it
helps me on the podcast because i just
think of something i just go off like
basically what i just did there i was
going to start talking about
my add and all of a sudden i'm talking
about a 55 ford
right and then i i bring it back around
and just
it helps on this thing having add is
great when you have a podcast
because you never run out of [ __ ] to say
because everything just [ __ ] reminds
you of something else you just keep
going but in my day-to-day life
trying to get [ __ ] done
um
and also trying to listen to somebody
else
like everything that they say
reminds me
i just reminds me of [ __ ]
other stuff and i just start thinking of
that and i don't know
i i even have add i'm just unbelievably
self-absorbed
[Laughter]
it's probably a little of both ah go
[ __ ] yourselves what do you want from me
um
so anyways yeah oh don't forget to get
your posters i did mention that i'm
scrolling down here and uh also
amazon.com is a great way to donate to
this podcast you just go to the go to my
website billboard.com you click on the
podcast page you click on the amazon app
and it just takes you to amazon i get
credit for sending you there doesn't
cost you any any any money and they kick
me a little [ __ ] money for uh
sending in there so you can go there and
buy a whisk
all right uh dude you called it here we
go the the reads for this week man uh
dude you called it bill
you called it last june on your
appearance on conan o'brien you told you
told conan that paula dean would be back
on television because she's a hundred
million dollar whale
i read today she received a 75 million
dollar investment from a guy who owns
sky mall
she's already in talks with a mate with
major television television networks for
a new show
great call bill love your podcast keep
being you yeah dude i mean that wasn't i
mean that was obvious i just predicted
that everything that
has happened before would continue
happening
uh she's back
she's back
i i actually don't have a problem with
paula deen i think it's refreshing that
she actually said yeah i've used the
n-word you know what i mean
she was honest
that's really what she was guilty of she
really could have just you know what i
should really shut the [ __ ] up because i
can't even remember what she did
didn't it start with she had a slave
themed wedding oh that's right
it's just what the [ __ ]
you know what she's like is anybody
watching uh the haunted house show
american horror story
me is watching that
this year and the theme was slavery and
i i [ __ ] i i can't sit there and
watch that with nia
because i'm afraid she's gonna cut me by
the end of the goddamn show and you know
i'm like going i wasn't alive then
um
that's what she's like the uh paula dean
is like the
what's-her-face the woman from misery
she's like the real live version of that
in that she's not like uh
some dead living thing she's actually
alive and she can make cookies
but other than that i think her politics
are the same
um all right female athlete of the year
is a horse
what
hey bill hearing the story last week
about the seattle newspaper snubbing the
women's championship reminds me of this
story from a few years back the daily
telegraph naming the australian sports
woman of the year and it was a horse
he's got the link right here i'll put
this up for you guys 2012 the year of
the london olympics where plenty of our
female athletes won gold and gave great
performances by our athletes he means
the australian ones
um they completely blew it off and they
gave it to a horse here here's the link
also ever thought of adding tasmania to
your itinerary when touring australia
it's the small island state below the
mainland if you don't know
got that welcoming
we don't get much down here so let's
make it a good one kind of feel
last time you were in austin you
mentioned how it sucked driving so far
to get to different places
none of that here
can cross the state in about five hours
and take in whatever you want in between
yeah if you fly
right
uh oh oh that's me oh in tasmania i get
it okay got some nice old theaters and
the best beers in the country not only
will you have a blast
i'll save 600 dollars flying over to see
you a win and a win dude [ __ ] that i'll
go there
they got some old ass theater
jesus christ tell me that's not haunted
how many indigenous people is that
[ __ ] built on top of
is it made out of didgeridoos um
sorry sorry for the hacky [ __ ]
australian humor i haven't been there
enough to give you anything original
i'll be there
um although i was upset that that that
uh bruce springsteen played perth
and his band played highway to hell as a
tribute to bond scott because that's
where bond was from and he's buried
there
and uh as cool as that was as much as i
loved it as an ac dc fan i was like [ __ ]
i thought i was going to be the the
american that goes over there and let
you know that i realized that bon scott
is from there i thought i'd get a little
star on my forehead and bruce
springsteen went over there and took it
right from me
all right i'm done with my temper
tantrum um
dethroning the bankers dear bill i know
how much you hate but the banker [ __ ]
and was wondering if you ever considered
getting into bitcoin
the decentralized nature of the currency
creates no need for central banks
controlling everything i'd suggest
creating a bitcoin wallet and playing
around with the small amount of bitcoin
to learn
how the system works it's the most
exciting thing in technology and finance
since the invention of the internet love
the podcast
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
uh and he's nice enough to to leave the
wikipedia um
definition either that or andrew
themillis let me know what this is uh
bitcoin is a peer-to-peer payment system
and digital currency introduced as open
source software
in 2009 by
pseudonymous develop
pseudonymous developer satoshi
nakatamota
two japanese people got the best [ __ ]
names satochi nakabota
it's a [ __ ] killer name bill burr
satoshi nakamoto takamoto
would you say that if he scored a goal
i can't do it
let me just continue here add it's a
wonderful thing
it's cryptocurrency so-called because it
uses crypto
crypt cryptography
now jesus to control the creation and
transfer of money conventionally bitcoin
capitalize
uh refers to the technology and network
whereas lowercase bitcoins refers to the
currency itself
um
yeah well the the big problem with this
is it's created by human beings i don't
think that bankers are necessarily evil
i just think that they have are more
evil than i am they just they're in a
position
to absolutely devastate everyone walking
the planet
international bankers have that ability
but i i really think that the more
um
i don't know the more i read up on it
and stuff it's just a bunch of greedy
[ __ ]
and uh like somebody's saying right now
the big conspiracy is that they're going
to try to bankrupt all currencies to
eliminate all wealth on the planet
and then come back with the new currency
and well i know that they're not going
to eliminate their own wealth
so
they're going to make everybody on the
planet broke except for them and they're
going to survive
now maybe they can do it but how do you
pull that off
that seems like that would have a a very
finite
um
life
before people were just like all right
i don't know about you guys but there's
like nine people left in the world that
can afford a three-piece suit and it's
not any one of us seven billion what do
you say we go over there and beat them
with their pocket watches you know it's
eventually wouldn't that happen
i don't know
um
yeah i i would just like to go back to
just open bartering just trading [ __ ]
hey i'll give you this shirt for that
sandwich i got plenty of shirts [ __ ]
going hungry again but look at my
waistline they look awesome
all right um i'll read up on it sir i'll
look up on it uh i'll look up on it i'll
read up on it and i'll look it up how
about that i'll do both of those things
i'll look it up and then i'll read up on
it a lot of up going on there all right
donation currency hey bill long time
listener love the show blah blah blah
blah blah let's get right to the point
um the person wrote blah blah blah blah
blah before you think i'm being arrogant
let's get right to the point you should
think about adding on another way of
donating on your website bitcoins
why is that you have fans and places so
[ __ ] strange that
you don't even know
where it is on the goddamn globe go [ __ ]
yourself i know where most places are on
the globe and i know they're capitals at
least i used to it's in my head
somewhere they use different currency
which might be a problem bitcoin is
providing an easy way to this is a
commercial
an easy way to transfer wealth use it
and welcome to the 21st century
by the way i'm from poland it's really
cold in here it's a second language all
right um
i i would think that if whoever starts
bitcoin if they don't get murdered in
the next calendar year then it's just
started by the bankers
um or they're just gonna buy it up
they'll sell out
right
i don't know i'm not gonna [ __ ] start
using a new currency
all right i i saw what happened with the
euro i'm gonna go with bitcoin that
started by some [ __ ]
hippie japanese guy
or even worse a businessman japanese guy
ah jesus christ you can't tell me
they're not still upset
by the uh
the two-piece we gave them back in the
40s
um adopt or birth
dear billy red billy red white beard
burr
thanks for the laughs and look forward
to seeing you soon in calgary calgary
calgary
i'll gladly take you out with with a
couple of buddies for some ice hockey
and a couple of non-alcoholic brews
unless you're back on the wagon yeah
let's get shit-faced and play hockey
dude i'm bringing my skates
you provide a right-handed stick
and a ski parka
i'll play some pawn hockey
um in which case we'll enjoy some
granville island
oh is that some bruise i don't know what
the [ __ ] if i guess i'm off off the
wagon granville island see
see what i'm saying you see how much
weight i'm going to gain up there
no but then if i play pond hockey i'll
skate it off
ah genius anyways my wife and i are
toying with the idea of either adopting
a kid or doing it the old-fashioned way
and making a baby ourselves she's only
27 so it's not like she's incapable
uh of making babies but she would prefer
to adopt a korean kid because a those
orphan kids need home b she'd like to
skip the crying baby phase and see that
korean kid will make me filthy rich one
day jesus christ doing what
um personally i think all what if it's a
female get it into golf because
they're destroying female golf right now
ladies
they're hitting off the lady t's there
personally i think all her reasons are
legit but i'm seriously freaked out that
if we give birth to a second baby i'll
love that second baby more than my
korean kid that happened to a friend of
mine who adopted and then had another
kid and was ashamed of himself that he
honestly felt more loved for the second
one even though he still loved the
adopted kid what would you do here if
you were me adopt or make one yourself
um dude i can't make that decision and i
think it's natural
that you feel more of a connection to
your own kid
but um
i don't think that would affect the
decisions you'd make unless you had some
sophie's choice that you had to make
i think your buddy's just being really
honest
um
i don't know i don't think it's a good
reason to adopt a kid because you think
it's going to make you money
um those orphan kids do need homes i
agree with a b she'd like to skip the
crying baby phase you know both of you
guys are a couple of psychos you're
trying to make money she doesn't i don't
think you want a kid
skip this crying baby face that doesn't
sound like a mom
what about when it can talk and it's the
whiny phase like i don't want to eat
vegetables
well [ __ ] you you're not mine anyway you
want to go back to the orphanage
do you know how much you cost me to fix
your baby teeth right that's what she's
going to do i think both you guys should
have a kid when you you want to have a
kid
for uh the right reason maybe you're
just trying to be funny i don't know
what
i don't know jesus christ
all right a-d-d
a-d-d
coming to a theater near you hey bill
you're a funny guy you amuse me
but before you go all peschy
i thought i'd run something past you
um
does that mean joe pesci are you is that
italian for fish i don't know what that
is your recent self diagnosis of add it
wasn't self diagnosis it was from my my
wife
i think could be ptsd he said not
showing me any sort of credentials
i'm not an expert okay so now i can't
sue them but i have a self-diagnosis of
myself with this condition ah isn't the
internet wonderful
i had an injury to the left side of the
brain when i was young which led to the
right brain compensating and in turn
this led to above average creative
skills hopefully you're just a naturally
funny [ __ ] but i suggest reading about
this condition
if you've been looking into that stuff
well i got run over by a jeep
wait a minute
wait a minute hey
wait you had an injury to the left side
of your brain that's where i got hit
i was riding on my bicycle i was trying
to beat my brother home i crossed the
street without looking and i got hit by
a jeep i was upside down
and i got hit right on the temple
so i told you guys about this before
when you when you
bite down on your molas bite put put
your hand right on the side
of you of your temple as if you're
pointing like ah that's a smart
suggestion there brian
yeah that part of your skull put it
right there and then bite down on your
molars
you feel that thing that goes in and out
that's right where i got hit and it
happened on a wednesday i remember that
because the doctor said i didn't have to
go to school for the rest of the week
and i got a four day weekend thursday
friday saturday sunday and my [ __ ]
jaw hurt so it hurt to open it hurt to
chew so i ate with a little spoon and i
had raisin bran i remember all of that
um
i don't know if that's why i'm
i became what i became i wonder if
that's true i have no idea i made people
laugh before that
i was i was [ __ ] killing it in
kindergarten
um that's interesting i will look that
up sir ptsd all right you know what that
is the podcast for this week everybody
that's the podcast for each of you now
go back to work
look at your spreadsheets not at your
boss and act like you're fulfilled
but secretly
take another step
towards your [ __ ] dream
before you walk in
and shoot up the office all right
everybody thank you for listening to the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to
you next week um thank you to everybody
who's coming out to the patrice o'neal
benefit it means the [ __ ] world to me
and everybody else on the show um that a
bunch of knuckleheads like us we
actually stepped up and created the
opportunity for you guys to do what we
knew what you would do and thank you to
the opium anthony show god knows they
move most of those tickets and all the
fans of that show
it's it's really um it's the highlight
of my year man it's
you